hello babblers my name is John Anderson
although the name might pass me as an
American I'm in fact Swedish well mr.
Anderson
the well-respected Swedish newspaper
Dagens netter had a headline on its
website that immediately caught my
attention now I got this from several
sources from our fans in Sweden so I
know it's true because I looked it up
and I hit Google Translate and I read
the article okay here was the headline I
[ __ ] you not this was in like the New
York Times of Sweden okay well hung
Hollywood heroes searching for God yes
you guessed it the DN had an exclusive
interview with Liam Neeson the reporter
said in the article again this is true I
looked it up Neeson had never been
involved in these scandals this is the
quote from the article when it
translated so it sounds a little honky
in in the translated English but you'll
get the gist of it Neeson is deemed mr.
nice guy who never created scandalous
headlines and spawned some rumors the
most persistent rumor Neeson is that he
is the most well hung male in Hollywood
at least if you believe Kevin Smith and
Ralph Garmin's podcast
that created a national movement with
people trying to outdo each other by
finding humorous parables on the theme
how big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] we've gone
international we've gone international
community my favorite part of the
article is this next line but Neeson's
genitals seem still not large enough to
overshadow his image as a devoted family
father fly fisherman and voracious
reader big reader is apparently he's
reading all these ancient books going
how do I shrink this [ __ ] well thank
you John for sending me that link and if
you look in the article the reporter
mentioned that in the article how random
is that it's just a shame it since it's
in Swedish it's not gonna get back to
him like if it was in an Irish newspaper
he might open it up be like who but
Swedish doubt I doubt he's gonna run the
article through a google translator but
he must have pressed people or something
to follow this stuff right Garmin is
your car late every week they talk about
your dick that would freak me out
somebody just came out to me and they're
like listen to this and they played like
a two-hour compilation bucket to
strangers go on like Kevin Smith's [ __ ]
is so little and everyone like haha
[Music]
you
[Music]